Sana International Airport in Yemen the
men leaving this plane are returning to
Freedom their houthis released as part
of a prisoner swap between Saudi Arabia
and the iran-backed houthi rebels
we are happy to return to the capital
center after we were in the prisons of
the enemy we thank Abdul Malik al-huthi
for his cooperation and for getting us
out of these prisons
it's a huge moment for them personally
but it's the realization of a political
breakthrough too around 900 prisoners
will be released in the exchange it's
part of a deal reaching negotiations
between the two sides seeking an end to
the near nine-year War mediated by Oman
the international committee for the Red
Cross is overseeing the prisoner swamps
look of Despair change now to a look of
happiness is exactly what's all about we
are proud
at the international Committee of Red
Cross with the help of our colleagues at
the yemeni red crescent to have
facilitated this that's the first day we
still have two days to come and
hopefully things will go smooth
landing at the same time in Aden was a
plane from Sanaa this aircraft carried
yemeni government officials released by
The houthis they included Yemen's Former
Defense Minister in the middle here and
the brother of the president behind him
of course it's a quite significant step
it's debating the mutual trust between
the legitimate government and haughty
and also paved the way to the peace plan
in Yemen Yemen's U.N brokered six-month
truce officially ended in October but
still largely holds the recent
diplomatic push comes as the two main
players in what is often called a proxy
war have made peace last month Saudi
Arabia and Iran agree to end their
seven-year diplomatic Rift and
re-establish diplomatic ties in a deal
broken by China this is the first
concrete result of not only
mediation but the Iran Saudi agreement
which is beginning to bear fruit in
Yemen at least if not yet elsewhere in
the region a significant moment most
definitely however finding common ground
between Saudi Arabia and the houthis for
a long lasting peace will take more work
and more time Rory challenge Al Jazeera